Speaker 1: All right. A couple other quick stories
that I will not spend a ton of time on right
now. Many of you wrote to me and said David Trump
adviser Stephen Bannon has been sentenced. He got
four months in jail. And that is true. But he's
not going to serve a day of it, at least not for
now, because of an immediate appeal. So the update
on that, you might recall that Trump adviser
Steve Bannon was subpoenaed by the January six
committee. He ignored the subpoena. He was charged
with contempt of Congress. He was found guilty. He
has now been sentenced. Indeed, as the Associated
Press reports, Bannon was sentenced to four months
for defying the January six subpoena. District
Carl. District Judge Carl Nichols, however, allows
Bannon to stay free pending appeal, a potentially
lengthy process, and also imposed a fine of 60
$500 as part of the sentence. Pretty strict, huh?
6500 bucks. Bannon was convicted in July on two
counts of contempt of Congress, one for refusing
to sit for a deposition, the other for refusing
to provide documents. Nichols handed down the
sentence after saying the law is clear. Contempt
of Congress is subject to a mandatory minimum of a
month behind bars. Bannon's lawyers said you could
give him probation. Prosecutors said give him six
months. In my view, said the judge, Mr. Bannon
has not taken responsibility for his actions.
You think others must be deterred from committing
similar crimes? Prosecutors argued Bannon deserves
the longer sentence because he pursued a bad faith
strategy, and his public statements disparaging
the committee itself made it clear that his
goal was to undermine their effort to figure
out what happened on January 6th. He chose to hide
behind fabricated claims of executive privilege
and advice of counsel, to thumb his known at
its thumb, his nose at Congress. Your Honor,
the defendant is not above the law, and that
is exactly what makes this case important. It
must be made clear to the public, to the
citizens, that no one is above the law.
So sentenced if he ultimately serves the four
months, because now there will be a very lengthy
appeals process and who knows, if you will, is
four months even a serious deterrent? And what
I mean by that is. Part of defying these subpoenas
to the one six committee is about showing loyalty
to the cult leader, showing loyalty to the cult
to Trump. I'm going to stay true. I'm going to
ignore the subpoena. If four months is all that is
at the worst case waiting for you on the other end
of it. It doesn't seem like a particularly strong
deterrent from continuing to show your loyalty to
the cult. Now, again, I have to mention this
because of the comments I'm seeing about, oh,
Bannon's going to get raped in prison,
he'll learn real quick. First of all,
the place Bannon is likely to go would be like a
lower security federal facility, the type of place
that Michael Cohen went to. There's not a lot of
prison rape happening there. But more importantly,
I've said this before and I want to say it again
when people talk about, oh, you know, even if they
only get four months, it's going to be worse
because they're going to get raped in prison.
That is a disaster. The fact that our prison
system is so ineffective at keeping prisoners
safe that sometimes their sexual assault
shouldn't be something that we relish and say,
well, you can count on the punishment being
a little worse. Guys, it's disgusting. Okay?
And I don't care if the sentenced individual
is a Democrat or Republican, a progressive,
a conservative or whatever. The fact that
sometimes people are sexually assaulted
in prison is just a reminder of how poorly
functioning our prison system is. So let's
not stoop to that level. Bannon is appealing.
Let's see what, if anything, he ultimately serves.